[Música]
vuelve
una gran satisfacción personal por todo
lo que sacrificas por todo el tiempo que
emplea en el deporte porque lo dedicas
dedicas tu vida a este deporte pues de
repente se ve todo recompensado y yo
creo que es la mayor satisfacción de un
deportista
[Aplausos]
[Música]
al final fue
con un sueño
[Música]
campeona del mundo
sí sí
felicidad
[Música]
[Aplausos]
tenía que hacerlo
bueno como se consigue lograr más de lo
que nunca imaginaste cómo consigue
superar tus propios sueños
me han hecho esa pregunta casi tantas
veces como estado de la de taiz cuanto
aguantas debajo del agua
gracias
churchill dijo el éxito es la habilidad
de ir de fracaso en fracaso sin perder
el entusiasmo y tenía toda la razón
lo que está claro es que nadie regala
nada
nada sucede por casualidad
y nadie nace sabiendo nadie malcolm
gladwell en su libro la historia del
éxito estudio casos de genios que
creemos que nacieron superdotados y que
triunfaron por su talento natural y sacó
en conclusión una cosa había algo que
todos coincidían la regla de las 10.000
horas todas habían dedicados al menos
10.000 horas en especializarse en su
campo
10.000 horas
pero entonces como como puedes dedicar
tanto tiempo a algo
y es que hay una fuerza invisible que te
empuja que te guía que te conduce a eso
que tanto deseas y esa fuerza se llama
pasión
la pasión es
algo que el motor que nos inspira que
nos motiva y que hace
que da igual los obstáculos que
encontramos por el camino nos hace
continuar
saben la pasión potencia la neurogénesis
que es la creación de neuronas se hace
multiplican si de repente solo tienes
unas pasas a tener mil un chollo
mejora las conexiones neuronales de
repente se multiplican las ideas y eres
capaz de ver cosas que nadie más ve
antonio damásio dijo una frase muy
ilustrativa en su libro no somos
máquinas pensantes que a veces sienten
sino seres instintivos que a veces
piensan
y si es verdad que las decisiones más
importantes de la vida no se toman desde
la parte racional se toman desde esa
parte irracional que te hace vibrar y
que te hace sentir desde la emoción y
así fue como yo me enamoré de la
sincronizadas
mis padres me inculcaron
como filosofía de vida del deporte y
practique casi todos los deportes y en
el momento de que estaba practicando
tenis uno de los días que iba a mi club
vivía mi club de repente
escuché una música muy fuerte no sabía
que estaba pasando y entró con mi
hermana vamos corre corre y de repente
vemos a unas niñas bailando en el agua
flotaban pero no solo flotaban y no se
bajaban sino que sonreían bueno para mí
un milagro
totalmente o sea me enamoré y yo dije yo
quiero estar ahí yo quiero estar ahí a
pesar de que me flote a pesar de que
tenga cero flexibilidad era un palo y a
pesar de que tenga vaya a cumplir 13
años y en ese deporte casi todas mis
compañeras de selección hubieran
empezado con 6
porque cuando tienes algo tan claro no
encuentras no encuentras límites
te vuelves imparable
seis meses más tarde
estaba disputando mi primer campeonato a
españa
yo quiero y contar las tres historias de
tres momentos que me inspiraron
profundamente que me proporcionaron los
aprendizajes más fuertes de mi vida
quisieron que me convirtieran quién soy
que consiguieran más de lo que nunca
soñar la primera historia fuerza mental
tenía 15 años a los 2 años de empezar en
sincro ya había entrado en mi 1er
mi primera concentración con la
selección a pesar de que mucha gente
había dicho que no conseguiría lo
conseguí
y estaba con el equipo nacional llevamos
tres semanas de concentración y tres
días antes de irnos a campeonato de
europa la mejor del equipo
se colapsa
de repente estábamos haciendo todo el
baile entero y en un punto se quita
no me había pasado esto yo ni en los
entrenos qué pasa
lo volvemos a repetir se vuelve a quitar
el mismo punto lo volvemos a repetir se
vuelve a quitar en el mismo punto y sale
de la entrega no entendía nada
y cuando acabo le pregunté
qué pasó
y me dijo no podía me ahogaba no podía
necesitaba salir me faltaba el aire
era muchísimo mejor que todo muchísimo
mejor que yo si yo podía ella podía
yo ahí entendí que si era capaz de
dominar mi mente me comería el mundo me
volvería imparable porque ya no era el
talento lo que primaba era el esfuerzo y
era la capacidad mental las fortalezas
de saber que podías hacerlo
saben hay mucha gente pierde
oportunidades por culpa de lo que les
pasa en la cabeza toman malas decisiones
en base a una mala actitud mental y es
una pena porque no saben con quién
hablamos más en nuestra vida
con nosotros mismos no puedo no no no no
estoy a la altura no voy a conseguir que
más te quedas
con nosotros mismos
si somos capaces de controlar nuestros
pensamientos podemos controlar nuestra
vida la autoconfianza es una habilidad
es la habilidad de creer que podemos
lograr lo que queramos y como todas
bilidad se entrena se entrena con
práctica práctica práctica y
respondiendo a esas mensajes
saboteadores que te envía tu propia
mente no puedo pues claro que puedo si
alguien puede en el mundo yo también
puedo y si nadie lo ha hecho nunca
porque no puedo ser yo la primera
persona en hacerlo siempre hay una
persona una primera persona
el 95% de las cosas negativas que
pensamos nunca llegan a suceder y
sufrimos por gusto por eso siempre habrá
alguien que dude de nosotros pero
tenemos que asegurarnos de que esa
persona no sea nosotros mismos la
segunda historia todo o nada
la gran apuesta con 17 años me retiré se
me retira de la sincronizada acaba de
quedar subcampeona de europa por primera
vez en equipos y yo estaba pletórica
pero bueno la sincronizada
yo quería entré a la universidad a
estudiar y
más retirar al año de retirada de
repente abre un periódico y veo
al equipo nacional que había quedado por
primera vez quinto en un campeonato del
mundo absoluto
yo no puedo explicar lo que me pasó pero
algo me movió por dentro y recuerdo que
en ese momento tuve la corazonada más
bestia de mi vida y pensé yo pudo estar
ahí
estaba totalmente convencida de que yo
podía estar ahí y me di un año de plazo
lo voy a intentar todo un año a entrenar
por la causa y si no lo consigo estaré
orgullosa de haberlo intentado
conseguí que me seleccionaran a la
en el equipo nacional ve y conseguir
convencer a la seleccionadora de que
quería estar ahí
y tuve que tomar la decisión más difícil
de mi vida
porque está claro que para tener algo
que nunca has tenido tienes que hacer
algo que nunca has hecho y yo ya le
había dicho a mis padres que nunca me
iría de casa
tuve que decidir irme a barcelona era
todo o nada y ahí entendí que para tener
alguna opción en la vida
para conseguir algo importante tienes
que pagar todo el precio todo el precio
y sólo así tienes alguna opción
y el precio significa
y sacrificio
y persistencia en el esfuerzo y asumir
el riesgo de que quizás no lo consiga
pero da igual
no tenía que intentar
hay que intentarlo porque si no
fallaremos el cien por cien de las cosas
que no intentemos la tercera historia
podría llamar la superación
al límite no sé yo creo que es el
momento que me cambió completamente la
vida
bueno quiero que imaginen por un momento
que llevan toda su vida invertida por un
sueño toda su vida todos sus esfuerzos
todos por esa causa que llevan los dos
últimos años fuera de casa momentos de
soledad depresión
la angustia la presión sobre todo
personal
imagínense que les llega la gran
oportunidad
y están eufóricos quedan seis meses para
moldear absolutos lo puedo conseguir me
llega la gran oportunidad y debutan
y ahora imagínense
en el avión de vuelta
a casa la seleccionadora nacional
despide hablar con ustedes y les dice
textualmente
muchas gracias por tu esfuerzo por tu
dedicación por tu entrega
ha estado muchísimo al equipo pero es
demasiado alta eres demasiado diferente
se te ve mucho en el equipo y quiero que
no tienes futuro
y estaba preparada para todo
pero para ese momento
no estaba preparado
yo recuerdo tener ganas de desaparecer
no sea
no entendía por qué algo porque me podía
pasar esto
y decidí
parar en seco estáis tranquila tranquila
tranquila piensa estáis tranquila piensa
vale ignora lo que te acaba de decir
olvídalo olvídalo
y agárrate a la única opción que tiene
es de cumplir tus sueños
es un ser humano se puede estar
equivocando demostrárselo
se lo voy a demostrar no sé cómo pero se
lo voy a demostrar voy a seguir
entrenando me quedan seis meses para
mundial moriré luchando me da igual
fueron tres meses
entrenando al margen
saliendo del agua cada vez que hacían
ejercicio entero
tres meses de una angustia de ver como
tu oportunidad se fumaba y como cada vez
estás más lejos y me llegó la
oportunidad
un día antes de la final de la copa de
europa una de las titulares se ponen
malas le dan vértigo no era capaz de
orientarse donde estaba la superficie
donde estaba el fondo no se puede tirar
en la seleccionadora me dice la
sustituya
llevaba tres meses sin entrenar esa
coreografía en el prometo que nunca ha
estado tan segura de mí misma como en
ese momento tenía tantas ganas tanta
rabia tanta frustración acumulada y
sabía que lo podía hacer que sabía que
lo iba a hacer
llegó el día llegamos dos horas tardes a
media hora de empezar la competición no
pude probar sólo 20 segundos
todo estaba en mi contra
la seleccionadora me dijo estás nerviosa
y yo no estaba nerviosa me había pasado
toda la noche visualizando esa posición
sabía exactamente lo que tenía que hacer
y lo iba a ser y lo hice
nunca había estado tan segura como en
ese momento y recuerdo como vinieron
todas las entrenadores a felicitarme y
bien a los seleccionadores y me dijo
muy bien
bueno si eres tan diferentes tendrás que
ser mejor
y recuerdo sonreírle y decirles si eso
me gusta más
eso me gustaba
saben la forma en la que manejamos la
adversidad tiene un fuerte impacto en lo
que podemos llegar a lograr y en cómo
vivimos el camino
insistir resistir persistir y nunca
resistir
porque es en el momento en el que
quieren tirar la toalla en ese momento
en el que ya no tienen más fuerzas
cuando si continúan aumentan sus
posibilidades de conseguirlo
hay que confiar como dijo steve dios hay
que confiar en algo en el destino en la
casualidad en el karma en la vida lo que
sea hay que confiar y hay que creer al
cien por cien de que todo lo que te pasa
en la vida se está acercando de alguna
manera u otra a tu objetivo a eso que
tanto deseas y a eso por lo que estás
luchando
anthony robbins dijo el destino depende
de las decisiones que tomes elige bien
porque la vida no mejora por casualidad
mejora cuando no permitimos que pase un
día más sin hacer algo que nos guste que
nos apasione que nos haga vibrar que nos
haga sentir vivos
creyendo apasionadamente en algo que no
existe lo creamos porque aquello que me
existe es porque no lo hemos deseado
suficiente
así que
crean que se puede sueñen bien bien
grandes y tengan muy claro de que los
límites están en nuestra mente muchas
gracias
[Aplausos]
[Música]